all right first of all Blake how
gorgeous do these fellow coaches it's
hard to be professional right now I
gotta tell you treading on thin water we
got we got Jen we got Blake we got Kelly
no Adam how do we feel like everyone's
rubbing it in it's so bad and like
badass it's awesome that's what it is
his team you know everybody wants to
make it to the end so that does suck
Blake I feel like you're not gonna be as
nice about well you know it is rough
freeze team but they did choose him as
their coach and you know he's a loser I
think it was last season you said if you
want he had to call you Queen Kelly if
you win at this one
no we don't have a better plan to
perform at your bar to get you to do it
but - I got cash I want something else
he has to wear these earrings my ears
aren't pierced did you ever have your
ears you have to get your ear pierced
and he's gotta wear these knows I'm
gonna win so I won't have says I want
you to get a tattoo of a chicken pock
tiny tattoo right all right well I love
it we're making the bets right now I got
a tweet we got a call-out - but for next
season though John Legend is gonna be
here what what advice do you guys have
for John well you know what you got
winner you think you know it all been a
coach on the voice
coming not no I'm not here to help John
Legend I'm here to beat John I could
give a crap about helping it we get that
two cameras I don't care about giving
you advice John them they pay me to win
[Laughter]
well you know we've got the spirit of
competition but I got a transition into
a way for the spirit of the holidays
what are you getting the kids for
Christmas I mean you got a big vacation
coming no we've got we've got some cool
surprises one but our big our big thing
that our whole family knows is where
we're actually traveling somewhere
holidays so like it's a snowy Christmas
and we're doing the whole thing Mike my
two-year-olds never seen snow so and
he's very animated I don't know where he
gets it from but so it should be pretty
funny the pictures like what are you
getting your special lady for Christmas
can you give us a hint a hint a big plan
a big surprise you know I like you but
not enough to tell you that but I would
like to point out that Kelly is so rich
that she is bringing in a snow machine
to Encino California for two weeks just
so that our kids have snow well come to
me Congrats short list for the Oscar
nomination for your song that you
performed right it's not short and it's
such a great talker it's such a great
song of course your shoo-in that's
amazing thank you how many of those
things do you know even if you don't win
short let's fan out have a naughty got a
Oh who doesn't want one of those he
knows an
oscar's you know what just get get get
all your loved ones and Oscar [ __ ]
like a little moment Merry Christmas
everybody
I'm getting grant a PEZ dispenser and a
candy cane yeah everybody gets a nose
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright last question for you guys Adam
Adams the loser he's not here sorry but
are you gonna get your friend a
Christmas gift can give him a
consolation holiday gift you know I was
trying to think of the past Christmas
gifts that Adam has given me I think I'm
gonna give him the exact same thing this
year which is a big bowl of error I'm
all quilts last year I was too busy to
see I was I have so many jobs and I
don't like - I don't like to source it
out I like to do it myself like you
would want me to buy all right like what
this won't suspect just go boss it's the
Kratt point I will Amazon Prime
something for you right now
[Music]